sur ce plateau hicham aboud vient de
nous rejoindre bonjour vous êtes
journaliste écrivain auteur notamment de
la mafia des généraux aux éditions
lattès
le pead est donc le pacte pour
l'alternative démocratique
il souhaite notamment à la mise sur pied
d'institutions de transition c'est quoi
exactement
bon c'est quoi c'est une tentative de
structure est en quelque sorte le
miracle à l'insurrection populaire savez
maintenant une année peu des millions
d'algériens sortent dans les rues de
toutes les villes du pays et tous les
malades aux six ans les étudiants qui
sortent et jusqu'ici on n'a pas de
résultats
d'un côté vous avez un pouvoir qui
réalise ce qu'il a envie de faire et de
l'autre nous avons un peuple
complètement en divorce avec ce pouvoir
qui est en place
sauf que ce peuple n'arrive pas à
réaliser ou à parvenir à ce dont ils se
réclament
c'est à dire plus de démocratie plus de
liberté et un état de droit aujourd'hui
le pead et effet un petit peu de données
aurillac ce que d'autres formations
politiques n'ont pas réussi à faire ce
que vous disiez qu'il y avait pas de
résultats c'est botman et avec le pead
et il peut y avoir des résultats
comment est ce que la population qui
sont dans la rue accueille justement ce
pead est jusqu'ici pratiquement n
accorde pas grand crédit au pead est
pourquoi parce que l'épée a dit pead est
c'est un ensemble de partis politiques
qui essaient de ceux de constituer un
rassemblement
pour répondre aux revendications du gala
et porter ses revendications au pouvoir
pour pouvoir négocier avec ce pouvoir
parce que jusqu'ici le pouvoir parle de
dialogue
or on ne dialogue pas avec quelqu'un d'
illégitime et justement le prd discute
avec abdelmajid tebboune le nouveau
meneur danse qui s'ils n'ont jusqu'ici
personne sous mais il faudrait quand
même créé une structure à même de faire
des propositions à même d'accueillir
d'obtenir l'adhésion du lkp parce que
jusqu'ici le prd n'a pas encore là des
sommes dues et comment l'avoir
l'adhésion du wihrel comme c'est quelque
chose en fait de populaire ce sont des
gens qui descendent dans la rue est ce
que le pead est peu dire comme ça au
millier ou million de personnes dans la
rue lever les mains et donnez moi du
crédit nous alors aujourd'hui tout le
monde prétend par des ennuis à lattes
à commencer par le président teboul un
président entre guillemets il faut bien
le dire ces ministres sont en bois un se
substituer à lattes à ceux portés par un
du rédac donc maintenant si à des partis
politiques de l'opposition des partis
démocratiques qui eux vont se structurer
et présenter un programme au nom du lac
sans qu'ils ne soient mandatés
ils peuvent par la suite accueillir
acquérir l'adhésion du mat
mais jusqu'ici d'abord le irak n'a pas
pour vocation de prendre le pouvoir
le kanak n'a pas pour vocation de
présenter
des propositions de faire des
propositions pour la simple raison que
vous avez tout un peuple
différentes tendances qui sortent chaque
vendredi et aussi tous les bars ni vous
avez des milliers des mousses n'est pas
des millions d'étudiants qui sortent
parce que il ya la pression qui se joue
un talent tous les mardis mais il n'y a
pas une preuve qu'il ya des
revendications mais a pas de proposition
qui s'en fait
et à ce moment là s'ils perdent et
parvient à faire une feuille de route à
établir une feuille de route avec des
propositions kinert concrètes qui
répondent revendications but irak et qui
va à son la négocier avec le pouvoir
pour parvenir à
faire entendre raison à ce pouvoir parce
que ça de le problème est là ça va
pouvoir qu'il s'entête à ne pas répondre
cela pouvoir afone il refuse entendre ce
que dit la rue lorsque vous entendez
excusez-moi a besoin de tes bonnes dire
oui nous avons satisfait la moitié des
revendications du peuple
alors que le peuple la première
revendication et leur demande de dégager
justement on parle du peuple d'irak vous
parliez de mardi les étudiants qui sont
dans la rue le vendredi
la plupart des gens qui continuent de
descendre dans les rues justement
aujourd'hui on est lundi qu'est ce qui
va se passer demain qu'est ce qui va se
passer vendredi à alger dans les autres
villes à oran ou ailleurs alost ribas
passé c'est que ça continue les sorties
continue alors qu'on a toujours tablé
chaque fois on sait de tabler sur
l'essoufflement de ce mouvement
insurrectionnel ce mouvement ne s'est
pas essoufflé ni ans n'était ni pendant
le ramadan ni en hiver
rien n'est pas venu à
venir à bout de ce match même les
élections 2002 décembre 2019 qu'on
croyait avoir pour faire taire une fois
pour toutes ces attaques et dire voilà
on a élu un président finalement ça a
donné 1 1 plus encore plus grave pour
qu'il soit encore plus fort mardi
mercredi vendredi prochain vendredi
d'après ce sera la même chose et
maintenant on va le 17 février
on va faire une année parce que la
véritable date de déclenchement c'est de
17 février et s'est sorti d'un tout
petit village s'appelle rata en petite
kabylie en voir la mobilisation ce jour
là disait qu'on re manche serait le
village qu'on a tendance à oublier alors
qu'il a marqué l'histoire d'algérie pas
uniquement 2019 et même en 1945 à srp
oui mais c'est le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
hicham aboud je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et auteur notamment de la
mafia des généraux aux éditions lattès
merci